I've talked a lot
about precession
and the changes in the
inclination of Earth's orbit,
but I haven't told you
why they are happening.
And I'm not going to go
into the physics of it.
It's a little bit beyond this
discussion right over here.
But they're really a
byproduct of the Earth
and sun's interactions with
Earth and with the fact
that Earth is not
a perfect sphere.
So if I draw Earth-- so this
is my little drawing of Earth,
and let me put the poles over
here, North Pole and South
Pole, it actually turns
out that Earth is fatter
than it is taller.
So if you were to
measure Earth's diameter
along the equator,
it is 43 kilometers,
which is approximately 27
miles longer than if you
were to measure its
diameter from pole to pole.
So longer than the
pole to pole diameter.
And the fact that Earth has this
equatorial bulge, that it's not
a perfect sphere--
and once again, I'm
not going to go
into the math here--
it's the interactions
between that,
I guess you could call it, that
one asymmetry of the Earth,
it's that interaction
between that
and the pull of gravity
between the Earth and the sun
and the moon that
causes these long term
cycles, this axial
precession and other less
noticeable changes
in Earth's orbit.
And as we'll see
in the next video,
these aren't the only types
of changes in orbits we have.
We also have changes
in the actual ellipse
that Earth's orbit has
actually rotates over time.
But that's due more
to interactions
with Earth's orbit,
and the orbit
of other planets in
our solar system.
And once again, it's
one of those things that
happened over thousands
and thousands of years.
So all of these changes,
they're because Earth
isn't completely symmetrical,
more fat than it is tall,
those interactions
between the gravity
of the sun and the moon.
And Earth's orbit, as a whole,
changes because of interactions
with other objects inside
of our solar system.